this year's polls have you been paying
attention consistently show that the
number one priority for Democratic
voters is defeating President Trump in
November one leading Democrat who agrees
with that is David Plouffe is the title
this new book certainly makes that very
clear what he's thinking he was
President Obama's campaign manager in
2008 went on to serve him as a senior
advisor Plouffe is now written a book
it's called a citizen's guide to meeting
Donald Trump he joins us at the table
for an interview that you'll see first
on CBS this morning good to see you
David Plouffe in your book you say the
most important thing is to get out to
vote even people even if you have to
hold your nose and vote that counts
that counts and that's that's sort of
what you said is the bottom line in any
election well got to get out and vote I
wrote this book so that the average
citizen understood the important role
they can play they can determine this
election because if it's close it is
gonna come down to an interaction at the
very end of the election where someone
says you know I'm not sure I'm gonna
vote I don't love the Democratic nominee
you got to convince them the only way to
get rid of Trump is to vote for a
nominee whoever it is so we have to
understand to win this election we're
not gonna win it with people who are
wearing your candidates t-shirt
necessarily or a bumper sticker on the
car but there are many people that don't
want to get rid of Trump though - well
there's more than enough people in the
country to defeat Trump even if we just
talk about people who are currently
registered but we got to register a lot
of people and turn them out and there's
a persuasion group that we need to win
so we we have math on our side from that
standpoint we just have to execute on a
lots changed in the last 48 hours Joe
Biden's big win in South Carolina Budaj
edge drops out what a judge leaving how
does that change this race do you think
well I think it does clear out a little
bit of the left center lane now a bunch
of people already voted for mayor Pete
Earley like in states like California
yes a early voting counts well yeah
early voting is important particularly
the general election when I get votes in
the bank I've talked about that book
but I think that means on Election Day
now you've got its segment of voters and
you know there were some states where
he's getting 9 10 12 % in polls yes so
that's got to reallocate so it's a
battle for the rest of the candidates to
show do you think this is a two-person
contest I do in reality I think Mike
Bloomberg is gonna get some delegates
and votes tomorrow and I think Elizabeth
Warren will as well but if you look at
who can who actually can get north of
4045 percent
Anders needs to grow but he's got a very
very firm floor and Biden I think with
the african-american vote now is gonna
dominate particularly in the south so I
think those are the two candidates we're
probably down to night but how can you
say it's a two-party race when Bloomberg
is counting on Super Tuesday and we have
an ad Super Tuesday yet
well we've got to see how well he does
tomorrow but I think he's plateaued a
little bit so he's spent
he's actually spent more money than we
spent in either one of our elections by
the way already
in the Obama years and he's gone up to
15 or 16 but I think because of his
performance in the debates
I think his inability to grow into the
african-american community in particular
there's a natural ceiling on where he is
but we'll see where we come tomorrow Joe
Biden clearly has to come out of
tomorrow with more delegates out of
Super Tuesday than Mike bloom but if
it's a two-person race is Bloomberg and
Warren are they spoilers in effect and
if so for which candidate for Biden or
for Sanders well we don't we have to see
how things come out tomorrow so
Bloomberg clear listen as much money as
he spent he hasn't faced a single voter
yet so I'm sure he wants to see how
tomorrow goes Elizabeth Warren's
campaign believed that there is a
convention play for them which I'm
skeptical of I I think that it's hard to
see how someone who's not the 1 or 2
number delegate vote-getter he's going
to be the nominee so again I think
candidates by the way mayor Pete made
history by winning Iowa yes you know is
our first gay candidate to do so but
also set a really good example of when
he saw there wasn't a path for him yeah
he made the hard decision to exit go
ahead well you know it would clear the
field if your former boss President
Obama were to make an endorsement I
thought you're gonna say I thought you
were gonna go this very same question
which is if we want a clarifying moment
on the Democratic side I think if
President Obama stepped in we've heard
that he's not a fan of Bernie Sanders as
an electable candidate do can we expect
any signals or signs from the former
president only four states have voted so
far yeah and I think we need to let more
Democrats have their say before listen
and at the end of the day I've never
been a believer that
even Barack Obama coming and saying I've
decided voters are gonna make their own
decisions exactly sometimes that
actually alienates voters if you come
into our lives right you say in the book
though that Republicans are consistently
they they are better voters and
Democrats in terms of turning out
without prodding yes
this is why I think the some of the
lessons in the book and ideas in the
book is so important which is they get
more reliable turnout and in the
battleground states there's actually
more conservative voters and liberal
voters right so we have a tough
challenge we need a great candidate and
we need a great campaign but if we don't
have millions of Americans in states
like Arizona and North Carolina
Wisconsin Pennsylvania registering
voters turning people out creating
content and making the case they have
Fox and they have Sinclair and they have
Trump and they have the Russians we need
people to tomorrow we will be right back
stay with us